now think this is not a right angle
triangle
right so you have two choices about what
you're going to use
what are the two choices sign rule or
cosine rule
which do you think is a better option
in some senses it's a bit of an
artificial question
okay because here i'm after an
h right i'm after a length okay
so therefore the sine rule doesn't have
the ambiguity that it has when you're
trying to find an angle
okay but just personally i always prefer
the cosine rule
and also like i need to include this
information
and these two right you see i've got to
bring them all in the cosine rule is the
only one which has three sides in it
three sides okay so here's the way i'm
going to do this right
let me just write this up the top so i
know exactly what i'm writing the cosine
rule
is like this right remember i explained
to you that it was basically
pythagoras but with a bit of a boost so
that if it's not in a right angle
triangle
right it's still this relationship is to
work because it just gets adjusted
okay so i need to know what c a and b
are
right suggestions
c is this guy over here right it's the
opposite side it's the one i know
something about
so i'm going to write that as 2 30.
okay a and b are just the other two
sides right the other two sides
so respectively they're going to be h
squared cot
squared 21 and then
h squared cot squared 26.
so far so good minus
two and then here are my sides again
right h
cot 21 h cot
26 that's my 2 a b and then i need
because of that opposite angle which is
71 degrees
okay so now for the first time after
spending all this time in the diagram
which is where the real worker is
now i have a liner working okay
i only need two more watch what am i
after when i solved before
h look h squared h squared
h squared so i'm gonna take out an h
squared
of this whole right hand side okay hot
scared 21
quite squared 26. um angles
two cot 21 cut 26
cos 71. don't miss that guy
easy enough okay now that's 230
squared okay there's only well okay i
cheated i said three lines are working i
suppose four because i've got to
approximate
okay clearly h for squared is going to
be
230 squared divided by all of this
rubbish okay now
legit people screw up at this stage
because what you're about to put into
your calculator is
a mess okay so let me give you a tip
that will help you okay here we go so
get your calculator at the ready and
follow along
okay you got it yeah yeah that's it okay
so
we've talked about variables on your
calculator before sometimes the
variable's like yeah you can use it
right you don't have to this time you're
kind of kicking yourself if you don't
you are
asking to get it wrong okay so here's
the way i would do it
um the most messy part are the cons
messy part of the card
because there's no cot on your
calculator you just have to do 1 divided
by 10.
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
call this remember
these are just a and b right in our
triangles i'm going to call
that one a that one b and then a and b
are going to appear again memory
right so in fact this is going to be a
squared and b squared and then have 2a b
there so
watch right to get caught 21.
i'm going to go 1 divided by 10 21.
so that's 21 right there so i'm going to
say well let's shift store put that in a
way i'll say it again
so one do your calculation one divided
by 20 and 21 that'll give you
cot at the bottom now it's really
important you have it
in the display don't clear anything then
you say
shift that's the store button above rcl
for recall
store and then you pick a letter all the
letters are there in kind of like red
magenta okay
so i'm going to pick a so now a is cot
21. see
that's what i've assigned it do exactly
the same for cod 26 you say 1
divided by 10 26 okay you say equals
and i'm going to make that shift store b
okay so now i'm going to go straight to
this line watch
h squared is equal to it's going to be
230 squared
divided by all right here we go
a you use alpha to get your letters back
you're pretty much
okay there's my a plus again use the
alpha button to get to the b
squared minus two
alpha a alpha b and then you need
a close 71 on the end don't forget that
guy there you go
okay so now i say equals and there's a
number
right seven zero four one
one okay
and then i want h right so you take the
square root
square root whoops sorry
and that gives me 83.914
which is approximately equal to 84.